we've got some big numbers coming for us
today guys this is going to be a hot day
we're going to do a big jump in
temperatures yesterday we made it to 100
today we're going up above 105. we'll
also get some help from some breezy
southwest winds for the afternoon 70s
all across the valley from nellis to the
lakes to centennial hills up at sky
canyon where mary jane bellies is
interviewing all those people talking to
him why are you waiting for gas for
hours and hours because it's free and i
can 79 degrees in seven hills right now
it's been breezy up in the spring
mountains 62 right now kyle canyon we've
got 52 in caliente some mid 60s at
indian springs perhaps back up to 70 77
for boulder city and 83 right now in
laflin let's take a look 107 so that's a
seven degree jump this afternoon from
yesterday 100 is the normal the sun rose
523 it'll set at eight o'clock
you know once we get into june record
highs are in the one team so i don't see
any of those in the eight day forecast
but i do see more triple digits as we
head into summer officially next week it
is staying chilly through the pacific
northwest the northern rockies and into
the northern great basin phoenix still
in the 80's for morning lows and all
these 80's will turn into 90's again
from the central plains through the ohio
valley and the southeast more heat
warnings and heat advisories with the
heat and humidity driving temperatures
to feel like 100 or more with that high
humidity at least we stay dry but this
system in the pacific northwest this
one's going to cool us down for the
weekend but between now and then it's
going to bring us a lot of wind and as
we stay dry
that's increasing the fire weather
danger so fire weather warnings for all
of southern nevada for friday and
saturday 107 today we'll keep triple
digits for friday but winds today will
turn downright gusty tomorrow we're
talking over 40 mile per hour winds for
friday and saturday so just please be
careful with barbecues or anything that
could get a fire started temperatures do
take a dive though into the low 90s for
father's day and juneteenth on sunday
and then right back to triple digits
next week as we jump into summer on
tuesday